就是上一週的時候我們沒有去講market
然後我主要是做了一個Q&A
我覺得以後可能一個月我會做一次Q&A
然後因為宏觀的市場其實並不是每一星期大的
CDS會變化特別多的
那麼上週的話有兩方面我覺得特別重要的
第一個就是大規模的Tag公司的Earning
那這裡我沒有去貼圖
但是大Tag公司Earning給到我們一個什麼樣的信息呢
就是我們說它持續性的投資
然後投資獲得收益
然後做更大的投資
那麼這個loop有沒有被打斷呢
這個我們叫正向循環
其實沒有被打斷
我們看到包括amazon包括
其實唯一一個業績展望沒有那麼好的是amazon
但是我們包括看到amazon的advertisement的廣告業務
它增長也是相對來說比較樂觀
從Meta到Microsoft
然後特別是Meta
因為像Meta以前大家覺得廣告是一個更加
怎麼說呢更加sexy
就是周激性的一個行業
它並不是一個高增長的行業
但是我們看到廣告業務在re-accelerate
就在重新加速
然後Meta明確的講廣告業務的增長
是因為AI的投資
AI投資帶來它的閱讀時間更長
然後廣告打得更加精準
那這些東西其實帶動了它廣告業務增加
那麼Metrosoft這不是上一周再上一周的時候
那麼本來大家預期是增長39它的廣告業務
那麼本來大家預期可能在lotharious
過去在lotharious之前還有人擔心可能會繼續下降
但是其實並沒有
我們看到所有的廣告包括廣告的一個增長
其實就是代表了AI至少在Mega7或Mega4
這四個雲廠這一端
它已經明確地產生出生產力了
那麼可以justify
可以去驗證它繼續的投資
所以我們看到在那個繼續投資方面
其實每個公司包括2020展望
就是營利展望不是那麼好的那個Amazon
它們都是明確的表示要繼續去投資
影響谷歌增加了100多億
然後其實每個公司對於投資的這個展望
都是非常明確的
所以這個是市場 positive side
我覺得市場有正面的有負面的
最近上一個星期
那正面的就是公司 earning
特別是AI相關的公司 earning是比較明確的
這個和我們從去年以來
今年年初以來一直認為的這個觀點是比較一致的
就是我們認為在半導體和AI的大多期裡面
這個週期裡面AI的使用和token的使用會越來越多
那麼現在更多的大家可能會在一季度或四季度
明年一季度四季度的時候會有一些擔心
說你們投了這麼多錢會不會繼續產生 earning
這是市場持續要去問到這四大運營廠的問題
但是這個中間肯定是會有反反覆覆的
就是我因為我現在預期很高
那我對於你後面而你能夠持續產生收益的預期很高
那我持續產生收益和預期很高之後
我有可能一兩季度沒有達到
那麼有可能市場會有調整
但是趨勢是不會改變的
就是AI一定會產生生產力
然後這個token的需求就是指數級的上升
沒有辦法很難很難被滿足
就供應不足成為大的方向
這件事情是很難被逆轉的
那我其實覺得很多華爾街的投資基金經理
沒有明確的預示到這個
但是大家覺得AI這個方向是對的
所以其實包括在做savvy就問到
就是說我們最近肯定是spear all outside
就是那個更多的買入買盤更多
除了對中基金可能會經濟出出的以外
其實大部分的投資人其實對於AI的信仰
是比較堅強的
就是覺得這個是一個供應革命級別的東西
所以你在很多市場包括我們說到負面的情況
就是負面的就是美國的經濟數據
那這個也是和我們
我之前一直是覺得美國的關稅
是不可能導致經濟數據上面是沒有影響
這是不太可能
那確實對於5月份6月份的這個nonefarm payload
進行了一個調整
然後我會具體說一下
但是因為星期五的時候
是聯合了matter earning一起打擊到了市場
所以市場影響是蠻大的
那個對科技公司影響是蠻大
但是你可以看到星期就有很壞的反彈
就是大家對於microtech
就是大的科技公司的這個持倉的信心
我覺得還是現在的時候
市場還是比較堅決的
那個我覺得說一下經濟數據吧
經濟數據層面的
其實兩件事情從經濟上來講
第一個就是關稅
這個關稅後面還會有多大影響
第二個就是我們說的5月份和6月份
對於nonefarm payload
對於非能就業的一個調整
那麼因為這個調整
其實特朗普腦修程度
把他的那個勞工統計局的局長也給撤掉了
就是他的意思是說
你在拜登時期把那個數據調得很好
然後到我現在大美利法案這些東西通過
我要先呼喚勝利的時候
你又把數據弄得很差
所以他非常不滿
然後把它撤換掉
那其實這件事情是很無厘頭的
那個為什麼呢
因為勞工部的數據
其實我是覺得勞工部數據上面
大規模作假的可能幾乎沒有
那人家不是跟很多國家不太一樣
就是能夠明目張膽的下作數據
那這個是犯罪的
那麼這一次勞工部的能防配入數據
調整有幾方面原因
第一個 你看它調整的這個方向
其實我們就是state
就是國家和地區的這個教育方面的這個工作
調整很多
那這個是不同的sector的調整
那這個也跟我們川普同學的這個政策是有關的
那麼一方面是跟這個政策有關
第二個就是在這個調整中間有很多see the moon
就美國的數據出來不是一下子會走的
它這個數據是統計數據
然後去問卷調查household
就是個人
然後問卷調查公司
通過問卷調查之後
它不可能一下子馬上回饋給你
它回饋給你一部分
然後根據這個東西去統計去算出這麼一個數據
所以它最後是會去調整的
跟中國很多時候做數據的方法不太一樣
那麼這一次本身respond rate就比較低
就是那個就是那個反饋數據就比較低
所以會有一些那個季節性的調整
但是呢確實就是我們如果看先行的經濟數據
就是QCEW
那這個數據是其實我們可以認為就是
對於是一個savage數據
對於那個可以對能方配合進行預測
所以而且match比較好
那這些數據來看的話
能方配合確實要經過不小的調整
那高省預期大概這幾個月
就是到三月份的數據要調整50萬到95萬
那就是去年4月到今年3月的數據
要進行這樣規模調整
這個調整的幅度是會比那個
是會比去年的調整幅度要大很多
那美國近年以來
那個能方配合這些數據調整
你看過去幾年都沒有特別大
就是今年以來調整都特別大
一個很重要的原因
是美國中間有很多的非法移民
因為非法移民的數據很難被非常準確的調整
你包括你會看到
像我們以前在投放的時候
非農和非農和失業率兩數據的這個
匹配度還是很好的
從區域你可以看到包括去年
這兩數據匹配度也經常
就方向肯定是一致的了
但是匹配度並沒有那麼的高
就是這個中間原因就是
Household的時候
它可能就是它的被調查主題都不會是
那個不會是那個非法移民
但是那個公司的所謂非農裡面
就是會有非法移民
再加上現在有各種各樣政策去針對他們
所以大家報數據的時候
對於非法移民就是沒有獲得勞鴻簽證
那些移民的那些人的
它的報的時候數據會有施針的
所以這種情況下
確實是會導致這個數據上下的波動很大
但我不覺得它是做數據
那麼這個數據變差
確實是代表經濟基本面在面差
而且我其實一直覺得
三季度四季度數據數會比較差
我們說過了三晚這個數據開始變差
會一直差到
我感覺可能會差到四季度
甚至明年一季度
這個都是可能性蠻大的
那為什麼
這個背後影響就是關稅
你加了6000億的關稅
就是Trump加6000億關稅
就相當於加6000億的消費稅
它對於通脹的影響
和對於經增長的影響
是兩邊都會看到的
然後通脹會變得更高一點
增長會變得更低一點
大概通脹會變高
大概我覺得可能將近1%的時候
然後增長會變差
大概將近1%
那這個事情就是會體現出來
那我們現在看到整個Tariff的規模
大概在Effective預期在18%左右
那個上週的話
很多Tariff的新聞出來
就是很多
因為8月份要到期了
它那個延期要到期了
所以它出了很多Deal
包括跟歐洲跟日本跟韓國
大概都在15%左右
這幾家佔美國進口的三分之一
最大的三家
中國、墨西哥和加拿大
就是這樣子
墨西哥已經獲得了Extension
獲得了延期
中國Bassett跟Bassett跟中國
看上去談得比較好
他後來表示暗示了它會給中國延期
所以這兩個大概率都會進入延期
加拿大態度是比較強硬的
美國對它很強硬
但是USMCA
它現在加了加拿大到35%
但是這個35%是USA Exempted
就是這個
就不是在USMCA
就是美國加拿大和墨西哥的貿易協定
法案下面的這個東西加了關稅加到35%
所以真正被加到35關稅的加拿大的出口品
沒有那麼多
大概10%吧
所以現在從關稅上來看
就是後面要等的就是我們叫Sectabase
就是我們叫什麼
就是特殊性關稅
就是對於某一樣產商品真的關稅
最早能夠推出的是銅
所以銅的關稅你可以看出
特朗普關稅的一個政策
就是他的嘴巴會好像很小
但是後面還是會不停的
就是直徑層面
會越來越感覺再偏鬆
所以copper上面來看的話
copper大概有一半的東西會被exempted
就是會被那個剃除掉
就是我雖然加關稅但是剃除
那我覺得後面更加重要的兩個Sectabase
一個是藥品一個是芯片
很有可能遵循這個趨勢
因為藥品上面加關稅的話
其實是個非常不得人心的事情
對中級選舉後面都會有影響
芯片其實它沒有這麼大的餘地去加
因為你要不產這個網頁
你除了TSMC那個廠還沒大規模擴建
還沒大規模生產在美國
還沒量產
然後英塔的廠就是給自己用
所以你真的是芯片
你全部加的話
就是在那個高後期行業直接加個稅
所以我覺得中間它會有可能
接下去會推出
但是推出的話
要不就是delay就像我們上上次講的
就delay很長時間推出
它可能會延期拖著
或者它推出的話
有很多很多的exemption
就是除外會比較多
所以這個是關稅上可能發生的事情
那麼就說這個
但是關稅畢竟是對經濟基本面
造成影響了
而且這個影響相對來說
會在會智慧的緩發
在後面幾個月會反發出來
所以我們會看到
比方說高深預期這個經濟數據
是失業的數據
現在肯定是剛剛開頭
還沒有嚴重
就是還沒有大規模的往下跑
那麼如果說
這個是高深的一個預期
就是對於real income
就是收入的一個預期
所以收入的預期和消費預期
你可以看出
經濟的就是對經濟的一個預測
所以他們是預測三四季度
會往下跑
就是比較明確往下跑
那麼最壞情況有可能
因為最壞情況
有可能是會放在明年一季度
就從經濟數據上來講
那麼數據差
並不一定代表股票要暴跌
股票暴跌的時候
一般是數據剛剛開始變差的時候
這個東西就說
美國市場用一個詞
叫Befecate
Befecate
股票上Befecate的這個詞
有點像冰火兩重天的意思
就是你在半導體和AI行業
看到的東西
和你在實體行業
更相關的行業裡面
看到的東西會不太一樣
就是我們經濟基本面變差
一定會帶動Corporal earning
公司的 earning變差
這是毫無疑問一定的
但是有沒有能擋住這個半導體投資
產出收益
這個大的這個週期
一定會對廣告業務有影響的
因為廣告本身需求就變少了
那麼但是
不一定能夠擋得住AI的這個
就是AI的這個公司盈利和交報
不一定能擋得住
甚至他經濟變差
就有幾個基督數據差了
他也未必會減少到CAPEX
就是對於這幾個大的公司來講
我覺得這個是有可能
所以我們會看到這個冰火兩重天
但是一開始經濟變差的時候
一定會對國票的價格
就是資本市場價格造成影響
所以我是覺得如果沒有進去
可以等著看看
就是看經濟數據
如果有機會
那我覺得在AI上面的這個大週期
如果有機會的話
是可以進去抓住的
就是那但是經濟數據上
三四季度我覺得是會比較差
三四季度比較差一個
另外一個原因是這樣子
就是你可以看政府的Expanditure
包括二二四年二三年
美國很靠Government Expanditure
但是你在這個數據是相當於
這個財政的支出
你可以看它財政支出
在二五年的時候
其實財政對於增長的影響
其實它是很小很小的
三季度和四季度還是很小的
就是幾十個TICS
二十個TICS之類的
所以真正的你說
特朗普說的這些減稅政策
全部實施它對於財政
對於經濟增長影響
它要到二六年
然後才可以出來
才可以有正面的這個反昏
但是另外一方面
Tariff的影響是負面的
那個負面的影響
在現在或者是三季度四季度就要出來
所以三四季度
可能是從Tariff的負面影響
相對來說比較嚴重的時候
這個是一個比較大的可能性
所以回過頭再講一個
大家都很關心的問題
就是沒聯儲會怎麼樣
再發揮掉老公部
老公統計劇局長的時候
那個特朗普也同時搶了
我要把那個就是
也去同時滴死了一下J-PAL
就是覺得J-PAL沒有降息
然後那個在拜登時期
搶了很多下
然後在我這裡
已經沒有去積極的降息
幫他吹喊
其實J-PAL這個人就是聯儲
我認為是一個非常專業的機構
即使現在不管什麼樣的情況下
哪怕特朗普換一個人上來
他也是一個非常專業的機構
那麼對於這樣的一個機構
他一定是看數據的
其實不銷Trump去推動這個事情
J-PAL在上週的時候
他其實已經有三次明確的表態
這個關於通脹的事情
通脹他表態是一次性的
一次性引起的通脹
所以就是說
我一次性引起的通脹
意思是我可以因為這個通脹
我不會因為這個通脹申請
它肯定
就因為它是一次性的
所以對我的決策影響沒有那麼大
所以它的就相當於我的
這個東西對於我決策的
在我決策中的占比是很小的
如果經濟數據很好
那麼有這樣的通脹影響
我可以減換我的降息
但是如果經濟數據變差
那我就一定會降息
就是一定會採取降息的措施
我覺得連處一直以來的態度
那麼對於
因為我們從通脹數據中間
核心服務和核心產品也能看到
這個就是輸入性了
那個核心服務
在就con-service
在那個12月到6月的話
大概從3.9降到3.4
然後但是con-good
從幾乎是0或者負的
到大概1%
就是那個Tariff導致的
因為Tariff現在
後面對通脹影響其實是一致性的
但是它一致性並不代表
它是馬上我加了
8月份 9月份就出來
有很多公司會吸收一部分的關稅
然後慢慢釋放出來
比方說現在吸收的比率
就可能是60%
現在50%到60%
就是很多都是公司在抗
那公司不過一直抗
它會慢慢釋放出來
所以它的影響雖然是漸進的
但不違抗
就是不矛盾
就是它這個通脹是一致性的
一致性的也可以慢慢緩釋出來
所以絕票明確表示是一致性的
就是只要經濟數據變差
美國就有可能降息
而且連主一貫以來
它是把增長是優先於通脹的
就是通脹除非很惡性的
那這種情況下
它也是一樣打擊的
但是在現在這種情況下
就比方說3.0
PCE3.3
今年可能是3.3
本來預期是比方說2.5以下去了
但是今年可能因為這個東西增長到3.3
這種程度和經濟增長之間的抉擇
它一定是覺得經濟增長
所以我本來是覺得今年
如果是按照前幾個月的這種經濟數據
就是那個能放PRO在沒有調整情況下
沒有調整情況下
5月份14萬
6月份14
將近15萬
14.7萬
那這個是我們認為12萬
8萬和12萬以下是連儲要警戒了
這種數據它是不太會去降息的
可能會拖到今年加2次或一次12月份
但是它調整到了1萬9
5月份調整到1萬9
6月份調整到1萬4
8萬以下就警戒了
那個
我覺得連儲9月份會降息的
這個這是我比較明確的一個感受
就是不是因為特朗普
把J票怎麼樣
他根本不會care特朗普怎麼想
但是經濟數據變差
連儲覺得通脹並不是他主要考慮
那他就會降息
好吧
這個是我對市場的幾個看法
因為上一周
Q&A中間也講到了很多關於半導體的事情
所以我這裡就簡單說一下業績
然後說一下經濟增長
就是經濟數據的情況
那麼連儲後面幾個
一段時間你可以觀察一下
他的這個態度
我是認為9月份會降
哪怕9月份不降
他也會給出非常明確要降息的口氣
大概率是我覺得會降
因為給出這個數據以後
他就是data driven
沒有理由的
就是說你不降息
你說你sited什麼東西說我不降呢
就是我現在通脹已經數據不好了
然後你說我要
經濟增長已經不好了
你難道說通脹嗎
通脹你自己說是一次性的
所以他要么就是很明確的說
我什麼時候要降
我後面一次要降
然後要么就是說直接降
那麼會不會降5
現在有人在說會不會降50個bass wind
我覺得50個不太會
50個又代表他前面政策失誤了
就是說我前面一直挺著不降
然後50個就說明我前面政策太緩了嘛
我急著要去弄一下
而且市場並沒有這麼大幅的下跌
那麼市場基本上反饋還比較正面
因為聯儲不太喜歡
資本市場泡沫太大
所以這影響他的這個工作
所以我覺得25點在9月份
這個可能是大喊率實際
好吧
我們訣略一下
看看大家有什麼問題